كارثه طبيعيه بكل المقاييس وقعت وضربت
بشكل اساسي شمال سوريا وجنوب شرق تركيا
ومتصدر الاخبار والعناوين والترند على كل
منصات والهاشتاقات عنا كمان ماليه تويتر
وفيديوهات القاسيه منتشره بكل مكان على
المنصات طبعا احنا بنتحدث عن الزلزال اللي
ضرب تركيا وسوريا اليوم بقوه 7.8 درجات
على مقياس ريختر ويعتبر الاقوى من عام
1999 في تركيا والاقوى من عام 1905 في
سوريا الزلزال صار في عشر ولايات تركيه
وهي اضنه وملاطيا وغازي عنتاب وديار بكر
وهاتاي واديمن وعثمانيه وعثمانيه وشانلي
اورفا وفي سوريا اصاب ايضا محافظات
اللاذقيه وحلب وطرطوس وحماه وحمص وخلف من
بعده مئات الهزات الارتداديه التي وصلت
لباقي المناطق التركيه
المحافظات السوريه وما اقتصرت عليهم بس لا
وصلت الهزات الارتداديه الى ايران العراق
لبنان الاردن ومصر وما زالت مستمره طوال
اليوم ومن ساعات تم الاعلان عن تسجيل
زلزال ثاني جنوب شرق تركيا بقوه 7.5 درجه
وصل هذه المره مدى للعاصمه السوريه دمشق
[موسيقى]
بسم الله
القتلى بالالاف والجرحى اكثر بكثير سواء
في سوريا وتركيا وعمليات الانقاذ لا زالت
مستمره وما توقفت وساعه بعد ساعه بتزيد
اعداد الخسائر البشريه اما الخسائر
الماديه فكما بالالاف تركيا اعلنت انه
للان احصنت دمار ثلاثه الاف مبنى تقريبا
اما سوريا للان ما في احصائيه واضحه لعدد
المباني
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد عمل اجتماع مع
الجهات المعنيه لمساعده المتضررين
والمنكوبين ومن دقائق النظام السوري ناشد
المجتمع الدولي مد يد العون لدعمه في
مواجهه الزلازل وخاصه في ظل الاوضاع
الصعبه اللي بتشهدها البلد هذا غير
الاحوال الجويه اللي بتقارب فيها درجه
الحراره الصفر والرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان هو كمان اجتمع بالقيادات وطلع او
طلع ووجه كلمه للمواطنين
منذ
[موسيقى]
مركزي كهرمان
طبعا الزلزال صار من هنا والناس رجعت
للتغريده
واستعرضوها وتداولوها وشاركوها حتى صار
عليها 25 مليون مشاهده وتغيير فجرت
تساؤلات يعني اولها وابرزها هل هو ممكن
اصلا التنبؤ بالزلازل ولو فعليا يمكن
والرجال تنبا وحذر ليه من عمل شيء والفين
اصلا وصل العلم بخصوص التنبؤ بالكوارث
الطبيعيه والاي درجه هذا الشيء بيساعد
الحكومات تكون جاهزه لكوارث من هذا النوع
خلينا نعرف هذه التفاصيل من البروفيسور
نجيب ابو كركي استاذ علم الزلازل في
الجامعه الاردنيه اهلا فيك معانا
حضرتك اكيد طلعت على هذه التغريده هل
تعتبر انه هو تنبا بما سيحدث
في الواقع من وجهه نظر علم الزلازل ابدا
ومن وجهه نظر المنطق ايضا ابدا لما نقول
انه اجلا ام عاجلا سيحصل سيحصل زلزال ما
معنى هذا يعني عندما نقول اجلا ام عاجلا
سيحصل جزاء انا بقول لك الان انه اجلا او
عاجلا كل البشر راح يموتوا هل انا تنبات
بانه تنبؤي صحيح في الواقع
اللي فعلا اصيبت
لو تكرمت لو تكرمتي اذا ظليتي تقاطعيني زي
هيك مش راح توصل الفكره لايناس فلو تكرمتي
خليني اكمل الفكره حتى نستطيع نفهم على
بعض في موضوع ليس سهل
انا اول جمله بس كنت بقول لك اياها انه هو
تنبا بالاماكن الصحيحه فيعني عادي ممكن
تهدي اعصابك شويه ونكمل مع بعض بهدوء
وحنفهم فكرتك اتفضل الان
تمام اي موقع زلزالي انا بقول لك الان
انني يعني لو قلت لك انه ان اجلا ام عاجلا
اي صدع في العالم كل صدوع العالم راح يصير
عليها زلازل فهل ستسجلي اني تنبات
بالزلازل على كل صدوع العالم
هذا كلام يعني من وجهه نظر علم الصفائح
علمه زلازل لا معنى له بتاتا التنبؤ
بالزلازل يحتاج الى ان نحدد مجموعه من
الامور اين سيحصل الزلزال هاي واحد منها
ومواقع الزلازل هي مواقع الصدوع متى سيحصل
الزلزال بالتحديد يعني لاقرب اسبوع مثلا
هذا لم يحصل كم هي قوه الزلزال اللي بتوقع
انه يحصل وكم هي احتماليه ان يكون هذا
التنبؤ صدفه عندما يكون في منطقه بيحصل
فيها كل يوم عشر زلازل اذا قلت انا انه
اليوم راح يحصل في زلزال هذا لا يعتبر
تنبؤ
فحقيقه هذا في الواقع هو عباره عن اشاعه
هدفها اثاره البلبله وها هي قد زبطت منها
بتصير البلبله بشكل جيد ليتنبا لنا بموقع
محدد غير سوريا
وتركيا اللي عمليا انا بعتقد بانهم الى حد
ما مستهدفين من الكثيرين في العالم
هذا يجب ان ننتبه له بشكل جيد ويجب ان لا
نكون ايضا يعني بسيطين وفي في تفكينا
لنحكم العقل والمنطق
وهذا هذه الجمله هي اللي بقول لك اياها
انا اقول لو قلت مثلا ان كل صدع في هذا
العالم سيحصل عليه زلزال ان اجلا ام عاجلا
اي اي تنبؤ هذا طيب بمعزل عن هذه اختصارا
من وجهه نظر علميه بروفيسور اعطيني هل في
طريقه او سبل لتحديد مثلا هذه المعلومات
حقيقه التنبؤ قصير المدى بما يفيد الناس
على اسلوب على سبيل المثال الطقس هذا في
الوقت الحاضر غير ممكن لاي امكانيه علميه
في العالم لكن ان نقول بشكل عام نعرف وانا
بقول لك كمان بقدر اقول لك انه تنبات برضو
في هذا الزلزال كيف كيف على صفحتي على
فيسبوك حطيت نتيجه جريده بتقول عن محاضره
عملتها في 23 في
26/12/1996 عنوانها الزلازل الكبرى تتركز
في ايران وتركيا والقوقاز وهذا الحكي من
سنه 1996 حكي علمي وهو مش مبني على اي
تكهنات مبني على انه هذه الحدود هي حدود
صفائح من النوع التصادمي حصل فيها سابقا
زلازل من هذا النوع ذكر رئيس الجمهوريه
التركيه بانه هذا اكبر اكبر زلزال منذ
1939 هذا صحيح لانه في 1939 حصل زلزال
قوته 8
هذا معروفه بعد ذلك حصل 12 زلزال فيما بعد
حتى 1999 زلزال ازميت اذا هذا التاريخ
لتركيا وما نلاحظ من ملفات الزلازل بتقول
لنا انه لا يمر يعني عمليا خمس سنوات بدون
ما يحصل كارثه كبرى اما في تركيا او في في
ايران وهذا ناتج عن تصادم الصفيحه العربيه
مع الصفيحه الاوروبيه الاسيويه نعلم ان
التصادم في كل مكان في العالم ينتج اعنف
انواع الزلازل واكثرها تكرارا كما يحصل في
اليابان مثلا المشهوره جدا بهذا المجال
وبعض سلاسل الجبال الاخرى